so I will talk about quantifying lower
bounds for finite variable objects and
this talk is based on a joint work with
Jacob Nordstrom form Stockholm so we
have seen finite variable logics early
in this morning so but let me give a
brief example because we have already
seen several other things today for
example if you express and first-order
logic that two vertices are connected by
a path of length 4 you can do it is done
that way by just existentially
quantifying the pass or alternatively
you can do it with only three variables
by moving the quantifiers inside the
formula and reusing the variables and
this is a three variable fragment of
first-order logic and you can even more
economic and save more variables if you
allow counting quantifiers and this
leads to the fragments EK which extends
the kaveri fragment of first-order logic
by quantifier saying there exists at
least I different versions of X and one
example where the serbs is for example
to express that the vertex has degree at
least seven in first order logic you
would have to use eight different
variables to quantify or neighbors and
with counting quantifiers actually two
variable suffice you can just say was XS
at least seven neighbors of X so find a
variable logic have several advantages
for example motive model checking
problem becomes polynomial time in these
fragments but one drawback is that if
you reduce the number of variables by
iteratively reusing variables the
quantifier rank might get larger and
what we are studying is exactly is this
phenomenon and see how we forget how far
we get so to make things more formal
suppose you have two finite relational
structures a and B
of universe of size M that can be
distinguished by a que variable first
order counting sentence that defines the
property of a but not of B and let a DK
of a bz be the minimal quantifier rank
of such a ck sentence that distinguishes
for structures of course if you do not
bounce the number of variables there's
always an n variable sentence of
quantifier rank em that defines one of
those structures say a by just saying
that there are in different vertices in
the universe and they satisfy the
relations as defined in a but if you
would use the number of variables a
quantifier rank might be up to n to the
K minus 1 and this upper bound has not
been approved in general but there's a
remarkable exceptions and I were to tell
you about to tomorrow mainly in the
three variable fragment you can actually
shape the logarithm factor and decrease
the point of a ring from n square to n
square divided by log m regarding lower
bounds so far only linear and our bones
have known for constant K by
constructions of martin gore martin fury
and for the two variable fragment by
oleg novitskiy and andrea scripts and
our main theory now is a lower balance
that actually exceeds the striver linear
upper bound in the cave area fragment so
what we show us a following for every
case there are two n element relational
structures that can actually be
distinguished by a cave area of a
sentence but every such sentence has
quantify our depths at least n to the K
divided by la case so nearly matching
the striver upper bound of n to the K
minus 1
and yeah and this result does not only
hold for constant k but also for k
increasing with em so in this range and
one algorithmic application is the
following so by the result of cairo and
emma one we know that the quantifier
depths of the cave where we are the
counting logic agrees with a number of
refinement steps the sort of K
dimensional vice where I Lehman ivory
rose needs to distinguish both
structures so lower bound on the
quantifier depths directly gives you a
lower bound on the power low complexity
say of the vice validly monetarism and
vital element algorithm has many
applications mostly for constant K but
there's also a very recent application
for non constant K that actually
coincidentally faults in our application
range in Baba is new Kwazii polynomial
graph isomorphism test she applies the
quasi pull poorly logarithmic
dimensional vice valid even algorithm as
a subroutine and our result implies a
quazy polynomial lower bound on the
number of refinement steps in this
setting so how do we prove this so
essentially is it is an errand for SC
game argument but in order to come up
with hard examples we combine two
methods from different areas from
descriptive complexity and proposition
reproof complexity on the one hand we go
back to a decades-old construction from
Neal so the so-called pyramid
construction which is actually also the
first case whether kailua mm and gadgets
pop up and MP combine it with a brand
new method from proof complexity
recently introduced by Alexander razbor
off and the connections that allows us
to use or to combine both these methods
are highly symmetric
formula so X or formulas as a sort of
heart instances because on the one hand
x or is a underlying principle of Sakai
for mr engadget and on the other hand XO
formulas also provide hard instances for
graham in a proof complexity for in
several settings so what's an extra
formula it's just what you would think
of so we have n boolean variables and
parity constraints of avg at most s
saying that at most s specific variables
the sum of them has to be either even or
odd so it's just a a linear system of
equations modulo 2 and the nice thing
about the extra formulas is that you can
encode it into to relational structures
that are isomorphic if and only use this
formula is satisfiable and the formal
definition is following and the idea is
that for every bull and for every
boolean variable you introduce two
vertices in both structures a and B
which have a unique color and then every
isomorphism could eva is ibiza identity
or flips them corresponding to sending
the underlying very able to either 0 for
the identity or one when they are
flipped and then you can define for
every constraint we also you have your
relations for every arity and you can
for every constraints include tablets
that n choose the following namely that
yeah isomorphism actually satisfies all
constraints for example it's a parity of
x 7 and x 8 has to be one yeah then in
this construction either the blue
vertices corresponding to x 7 or the
blue red vertices corresponding a 2x8
has to be flipped by an isomorphism so
there as a morphic if and only if the
underlying extra formula is satisfiable
and now we can play the following pedal
game on XO formulas which corresponds to
the errand for IC game on the
corresponding structures so this is a
following we have two players player 1
and player 2 and the positions are
partial assignments of the variables
from the XO formula and in each round
player one picks up some pebbles so
delete some assignments and ask for
variable X and player 1 player 2 answers
with zero is a 0 or 1 and the game
continues and play a one wins the game
of some partial assignment of K
variables are file suffice and initial X
or constraint and now it's not hard to
see that this actually corresponds to
the errand for us a game of the
structure encoding namely that player 1
wins our round k / the game on the XO
formula if and only if there's a
variable sentence of quantifying our
that distinguishes both structures so in
order to prove quantifier ranked lower
bounds we prove a lower bound on the
number of rounds in that game and the
connections to prove complexity knows
the following if you view these X or
formula as CNF formula and try to find a
resolution refutation of that formula
then they are one wins are on Cape have
the game if and only if you have a
resolution refutation of with K minus
one where every clause in the reputation
contains at most K minus 1 literals and
the depths of the reputation is our yes
it equal insisted on F being a test
formula or yes so this does only work
for this extra formula and for this
particular structure and coding and the
proof now works as follows so we start
with the old construction from Neil that
actually gives a lower bound of two to
the square root lock and for the caper
game for an arbitrary number of pebbles
and we rescale it so that it only works
for the pebble number between three and
K but by doing this we are able to
improve to improve this lower bound to
enter the one over la que and the second
step we do know is to apply is the
hardness condensation method from proof
complexity and to reduce the number of
variables in the XO formula fairly
dramatic so we use a number of variables
from n to n to the 1 over K but we do
this in such a way that we don't destroy
the round lower bound in the pebble game
and so the new lower bound becomes M to
the K over la que in terms of the new
number of variables them
so the first part the pyramids so the
construction looks as follows so this is
a two dimensional pyramid it's a
directed graph and we construct X or
formula orders to drag directed graph as
follows we label all sources with zero
and we label the sink with one and for
every vertex and we say that the parity
between a vertex and it in the incoming
neighbor has to be even and then the
whole formula becomes unsatisfiable and
actually we can prove that it's
unsatisfied with only three pebblez a
winning strategy would look as follows
so first player whatever the sink second
player has to answer one and then it
would pebble both incoming neighbors and
as the parity between all these labels
has to be odd one of them has to be one
then firstly I can pick up pebbles
pebbles incoming neighbors of set vertex
one of them has to be one and then you
continues babbling the one to the button
and this gives in contradiction because
sources has to be labeled with 0 and
then yeah the number of rounds player
one needs is obviously the height of
this pyramid and in this Republic game
and and now we want to have this
construction also for a higher number of
pebbles center-north seduces we switch
to pyramids of higher dimension so the D
dimensional pyramid of height H so this
is an example of three dimensional
pyramid it's do a directed graph of in
degree to where the edges I'll a
director from bottom to the top so
player 1 can still win the 3 para game
by just babbling z1 from the top to the
bottom but he needs the number of rounds
he needs as linear in the height of the
pyramid and this also holds if the
number of pebbles increases up to
exponential and the diamond
of the pyramid and yeah as a pyramid has
height to the d vertices where d is a
dimension we get a lower bound of n to
the one novel ok ok and this brings us
already to the second part as a hardness
condensation what we now do is we want
to take this lower bound and just reduce
the size of the universe without
destroying the lower bound this sounds
suspicious at the first place but it
somehow works so the trick is the
following we have we take a bipartite
graph g with vertices you on the
right-hand side and the vertex set V on
the left-hand side so that vertices on
the right hand right hand side are the
variables from our original X or formula
F we start with so in our case these
high dimensional pyramids and the new
set of variables we have on the right
hand side and then we just do the
following so for every X or constraint
we in the variables of the of this site
we substitute every variable with the
neighbors in this bipartite graph so we
substitute you to buy a v2 v3 v4 and you
five by v4 or v6 and this gives us a new
X or formula in the variables of the
right hand side and in order to reduce
the number of variables we take
bipartite graphs where this site is
strictly smaller and actually we take
boundary expander with left degree K
over 3 so that's a left hand side number
of regulate this n which is a number of
areas of the high dimensional
it's a number of the new variable it is
only n to the 1 over K and now what
happens so the first thing you can see
that also works if the bipartite graph
is not an expander that if player 1 wins
the three pepper game here then he wins
a capable game here because whenever he
would play a pebble on that variable he
could instead in this graph tab all
neighbors of that variable and the
tricky thing now is to prove the other
direction so if player 2 survives the
hour round k / the game on earth then
she survives the are round capable game
on the new formula and yeah and this
actually is a hard part of the proof and
uses the expansion property so this
method was introduced by ross perot off
quite recently and area of proof
complexity to show that free libraries
you lose data and that they are formulas
as it can be refuted in Witzke but where
every witzke refutation every tree like
Witzke reputation has size a doubly
exponential which is quite remarkable
because in the worst case you could
always find an exponential size
reputation of former so if we don't
restrict to its and this technique has
also been successfully applied in other
settings for example for linear
programming hierarchies to say that the
rank of the lava shriver hierarchy
explodes if you restrict the degree and
furthermore will together with the okapi
shows that we get also trade-offs
between space and widths and resolution
and as of last week ross perot of
announced another resort saying that
applying this method to get a variable
space versus lengths trade-offs so it
seems that that this techniques to
reduce your instance in order to
increase your lower bound helps you in
various setting and maybe it also helps
you to solve your problems okay so this
was already my point and let me conclude
so we proved a near-optimal lower bound
on the quantifier depths of AK and ck
which nearly matches a trivia upper
bound and also has applications to the
number of refinement steps of service
file alignment algorithm one
interviewing open problem is that our
examples are actually decay every
relation is structures and we would like
to know whether there are similar lower
bounds for graphs so yeah it's near said
yesterday everything is a graph and we
believe that this also holds in this
setting but we are not able to prove
this because by substituting with high
degree you
automatically introduce a constraints of
higher degree and this causes a problem
yeah okay and this computer
so remind me when k is equal to 2 and
you are talking about graphs and there
was some earlier result that right so if
k is equal to 2 then you as a no a la
bonne says nothing because of these big
Omega and the exponent but y'all ready
lower bounds for linear number of
refinement steps so you can rather
easily see that you get a lower bound of
one-half times n and this was bye-bye
clips in povitsky or leaks last year
improved to n to the minus little o of
em so nearly linear
so this is kwl algorithm so this is an
refinement algorithm that solves it
cancer is a different dimension so the
bottom dimension is the color refinement
algorithm that agrees with fractional
isomorphism so you iteratively refine
the partition of the vertex set into
equal vertices and K dimensional vice
valid email algorithm partitions k
tuples of the vertex set
questions
so that's time